these are the best known abilities in
Hunter Hunter which we've discovered
according to the greatest scientific
measure on the planet a YouTube
Community post nov's hide and seek is
the obvious winner I mean say what you
want about the methodology this this is
a very good start the insane utility of
this hot suit cannot be overstated
unless you say that he can create 22
rooms that would be overstating it
because nov can only create 21 magical
pocket Dimension rooms but the key thing
about this ability is that it's
essentially teleportation as well and
one thing I've always wondered is if nov
has a limit on this as far as we know he
could place a portal on two different
continents enter his Mansion through one
and then in a matter of seconds use
another exit to appear on the other side
of the world it really is a shame he's
not going to the Dark Continent because
his ability would have made fleeing back
to the human realm much much easier and
then you have the ridiculous power that
is screamed where nov can open a portal
between his hands and close it on
anything which is a genuinely merorem
killing maneuver if you could ever get
close enough to pull it off hide and
seek also says a lot about North himself
it's very well reasoned and very logical
but it also allows you to run away it's
very much the ultimate ability during
nightmares when you've got something
chasing after you something not lived in
reality after being exposed to a very
Sinister end and the hunter hunter
mabaga card game is a little bit sad
when it comes to nov because he goes
from a very well put together gent to a
silver fox to a complete and utter
mental breakdown and ultimately
finishing as a dude hiding in a bush
also nov's name is almost certainly
based on the word knob as in doorknob
sir so that's fun biskey's cookie
massage the Sleep the relaxation the
extra time would be Godly I spoke about
this a lot in the transmuter tier list
video but this power is simply broken
magical spa services essentially
eliminates the human need to sleep
instead replacing it with a 30 minute
massage every day and it's not just
sleep it's the illumination of fatigue
in fact there may come a point in your
life with this ability that you can't
even identify with the concept of
fatigue anymore in addition to all of
the long-term health benefits of being
massaged by a cartoon woman allegedly
provides apparently they are numerous
also this video is sponsored by loot boy
who we've partnered with to create a
special ground Line review Premium Pack
full of awesome one-piece prizes
everyone can download lootboy for free
it's available on Android IOS app
gallery or even PC and then you can
collect delicious coins to open free
packs however there are also amazing
premium packs and you can open them in
one of two ways the first way is your
classic real money you know your dollars
your pounds your Euros the general fiat
currency but there's also diamonds which
allow you to open Premium packs for free
and what we're gonna do is open a bunch
of ground Line review premium packs and
Bam that right there is one month of
free Crunchyroll premium plus I got a
whole ton of other cool stuff including
full PC games however within the
groundline review premium packs you can
also crack up to 12 months of
Crunchyroll free the new one-piece
Odyssey game and the first four manga
box sets that cover everything from East
blue all the way to the reverie plus
with loot boys free new chat radar
feature you'll find new friends and new
gaming teammates in easy and fun ways
because chatradar automatically matches
you to other Gamers who share your
interests and tastes in gaming thus
doing all of the hard work and you doing
all of all of the not that and for each
pack opened a diamond is added to the
jackpot the entirety of which is awarded
to one lucky player each week you can
check out the link to loot boy in the
video description and using code New
World review within the app gives you a
community pack with diamonds loot coins
and much more so do that thing but for
now it's back to you me so if we're
talking about this vs hide and seek then
I would honestly go with magical spa
services it's not the craziest it's not
the coolest or most utility packed skill
but it's the one that would
revolutionize your life the most
primarily by giving you more of it you
get to live more out of every day and
your health is kind of curated to make
you exist as long as possible plus it
also gives you a pretty easy career
someone with this ability could make
stupid quantities of cash money selling
their skills to pay their various bills
and the best part is that maybe you
could even use it to help tagashi's back
and get us some faster chapters whatever
Jing has it's probably op they see you
also like to live Danger seriously this
is quite fun because this comment is
like going to the nen casino and just
betting everything on red whatever that
guy has I'll take it and now go and
watch Jing have an absolutely terrible
ability for anyone that isn't him I'm
surprised people haven't mentioned call
Toby's ability yet I I don't know if I
am so we're talking about Gallery fake
which gives its user the ability to
conjure an exact replica of an object
that lasts for 24 hours notably you can
replicate living things which is minus
the living part so just things I guess I
mean for example if you did do it with
the person then you would just create a
temporary corpse and it's pretty good
for a situation where you say
immediately want to double all of the
money you currently have and spend that
conjured cash on some sweet sweet
products of your choosing I don't know
whatever you spend your money on but you
would be effectively spending nothing in
fact you might even be able to Loop this
and conjure your conjured money and just
keep it going but also maybe not because
cortobi can conjure conjured objects but
they lose any special powers attached to
them in this case the special power
would be kotobi special power which is
existence so they would lose their
existence in general I feel like this
ability would lead to a lot more trouble
than it was worth though especially when
people start realizing that all of their
stuff is disappearing but it does have a
very underrated benefit which is that
cortobi can track all of the objects he
conjures so it can act like a tracking
bug with extra steps and for a very
limited time period and one way you need
to actually find an object copy first
and just uh look it's interesting but
it's definitely not one of the best
great Haiku Basho there are no drawbacks
when using it is independent of other
circumstances to use presumably not very
or consuming Limitless application I
personally consider this to be one of
the top 5 best known abilities and it's
also a bit of a relic of early Nan back
when the power system was still being
formulated we ended up with a lot of
powers that were either just way too
powerful or way too not that like
pathetically weak but great Haiku is an
example of the former the gist of this
heartsu is that anything you write down
as a poem will come to life but its
quality depends on how good the poem is
which is a really cool restriction
mostly because there's no objective way
to judge how good a poem is unless it's
like really bad and I think that's where
the internal balance comes from the
judge in this case is probably Basho
himself who has this complete lack of
confidence in his own work he thinks
what he writes is garbage so his
abilities emerge as garbage I actually
wonder if this ability could even exist
with someone who thought they were a
great poet I mean it probably could but
the aura cost would be outrageous
because think if you're a narcissistic
poet then everything you write is the
best thing ever which means that you
would always be Conjuring the best thing
ever and Conjuring the best thing Evers
requires a lot of Aura sounds very
intensive in addition to being a written
poet though Basho is also a lyrical poet
having engaged in at least one rap
battle against Ridge a god of Prince
losers with my assumption there being
the boss show more than likely lost one
due to his lack of self-confidence and
two because Ridge takes his rapping very
very seriously melioron you wouldn't
even really need his additional
abilities just the invisibility alone is
so useful so here's the often confusing
thing meliron's invisibility isn't an
ability it's a natural power that comes
from the fusion of ant chameleon and
human so the dude can just whack on an
invisibility cloak without even using a
single drop of Aura but the true Ability
Beyond that is perfect plan this is a
hotsu that allows melioron to conceal
his existence entirely he cannot be seen
heard smelt or even detected using n but
he can only do it whilst holding his
breath so it's pretty naturally limited
but it's a simple palette with a simple
cost and really who doesn't love
invisibility if you ask someone with
superpower they'd want the answers would
generally be either flight teleportation
or invisibility so even breath holding
invisibility would manage to police 33.3
percent of the world and again the great
thing is that this is about as plug and
play as you can get with nen
straightforward power straightforward
conditions and amazing results Felix
salesman but it's hard to argue with
such efficient Simplicity morals is just
so cool and it has many possible uses
the most versatile one in Hunt to Hunter
Hunter probably so we've just gone from
Simplicity to now overly complex but I
definitely can't think of a power that
has more versatility than morals Deep
Purple Moroccan effectively turn smoke
into any object any structure or even
living being with a limited range of
functionality which isn't restricted to
Smoky appearances either apparently
moral can nigh on perfectly imitate the
colors and texture of whatever he so
desires which provides Deep Purple with
an inbuilt texture surprise it's hard to
think of something more desirable than
the ability to have literally anything
you need in any situation so
conceptually putting this up against
magical spa services is a bit of a tough
choice but one I think tips the scales
in Biscuit's favor is the fact that with
deep purple you need to carry around
this massive massive pipe which would be
a massive massive pain to cut around and
you'd probably get some real weird looks
everywhere you go and probably be
regularly stopped by the police because
it's like no officer you don't
understand I use this blunt weapon
looking thing to smoke bunnies into
existence I don't think that'll go very
well understand though it's a very
strong Contender for best nenability
Castro's net ability so I can punch
myself fair enough if I could have any
ability in this series and I chose
Castro's then I would also want to punch
myself Al 100 never take more than one
trip with groceries never worry about
parking never worry about travel fees
renting a car or keeping valuables safe
I was hoping someone would bring this up
because the fun fun cloth always gets
forgotten about and why it's so much fun
this incredibly underrated ability can
shrink anyone and anything that ends up
in the cloth which was used against the
Phantom troop and even ended up
capturing Nobunaga granted that was
because he had a bit of a bad spot in
the car but under the right
circumstances the fun fun cloth one
shots a troop member because Nobunaga
himself couldn't do anything to get out
of it this ability was deemed to be so
good that the troop even kept Al alive
so that crawler could steal the fun fun
cloth which he attempted to use in his
fight against the zaldics I assumed that
he wanted to capture them in the cloth
and then maybe use that somehow to steal
their powers doesn't really matter
because it didn't really work at all in
the end chroma just conjured a cloth
held it out like a matador probably said
Olay in his head and then deconjured it
again just a bit of fun mid-battle and
surprisingly the character of Al does
appear in the mumbaga card game making
this very deranged expression and doing
what I'm told the world of nature would
describe as presenting but the fun fun
cloth is amazing Al is terrible terrible
owl man but an amazing then ability
jijankan obviously kazai can play Rock
Paper Scissors without any arms you know
that's very true gone could still make a
rock even without an arm so if scissors
paper rock was your priority in life
then this is 100 the way to go I'm
surprised nobody has thought to mention
Alika as long as your Wish isn't greedy
it doesn't screw anything over I mean it
does no matter what the wish is it
screws something over but I think the
reason why not many people mention it is
because it's not actually a very good
ability for the user a lot of people
confuse this but alaka Khan actually
wish for anything herself or I suppose
more accurately nanika because nanika is
the Dark Continent creature I the
codependence of Desire meaning that
nanaka's power is entirely dependent on
the desires of another other people make
the wish and you just facilitate the
costs and the outcome you're basically
becoming a glorified nen Logistics
service and just like in the series
you'd either be seen as a danger to Life
as We Know It And eliminated it once or
coveted as the Ultimate Weapon or
perhaps even both it really just doesn't
sound like a great life and also even if
things do go well you could end up being
responsible for some of Humanity's
greatest atrocities depending on the
wish and depending on the cost the very
best case scenario would be turning you
and your brother into a gimmick Cafe
drink which is the thing that actually
happened and look if that's the best we
can hope for then I think that we should
just maybe pursue something else 100
type guanyin borisatva I have already
renounced my old gods and begin my time
of seclusion with punches and prayer so
a lot of people cite this as the best
known ability and I think they often
confuse best with most powerful because
yes it is absolutely one of the most
powerful but definitely not quite one of
the best to make any decent use of it
whatsoever you need that superhuman
prayer speed that took natural God knows
how many years of isolation to achieve
without that using it in a fight would
probably even be detrimental always
thinking of which hand to use and which
of the 99 prayer motions you need to
make you do this one to do this ones you
do these ones which ones there's a lot
of them to learn and by the time you've
gone through all of that thought process
your opponent has likely already
engulfed you in his fun fun cloth and
it's a sad sad time for you it would
also take so much time and dedication to
use this as well and even when you get
to that level of being able to use it it
still really only has one purpose which
is to engage in fight battling so if you
wanted to become a battle-hardened
warrior then sure but for everyone else
netro's alternate career path is a much
better choice which is apparently to
become Santa because when you're an old
man you tend to only have two employment
options either it's a grizzled martial
arts master or you become Santa that's a
that's your choice but when it comes
down to it the best ability is going to
be either this game moral or not whiskey
if you want to live the happiest and
most fulfilling life possible moral if
you value having anything at any time
and nov if you like moving as little as
possible